what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i have a
special guest on the channel
yes it's me ally i am pearl's friend in
real life and i finally got to meet her
for the first time there's not a whole
lot of red pill women out there so i'm
very fortunate that i got to meet you
and i'm happy to be your friend we're
besties now yeah yeah and today we're in
the kitchen where we belong yes and i
enjoy being in the kitchen i cooked for
my man today already so some feminist
out there is upset with me hey guys
check this out studies have shown that
our appearance affects our mental health
and the anti-aging industry has tried to
capitalize on this for decades
unfortunately many of these anti-aging
products just don't work this is because
most serums and supplements don't target
the source of the problem this is why
i'm such a fan of multi-collagen
multi-collagen works quickly to restore
youthfulness back to your skin it helps
by combating loose skin and wrinkles and
it does this quickly and more
effectively than anything i've ever
tried we all know summer is coming
imagine how good your skin could look by
summer with taking it if you want to
look good and feel your best grab some
multi-collagen today get up to 51 off in
the next 24 hours by going to
healthwithpurley.com or by visiting the
link in the description on top of that
there's a 60-day money-back guarantee
how convenient and free shipping with
every order get yours today all right so
i brought her on the channel guys
because she is a real life housewife yep
receipts there you go
so today we're going to be watching emma
watson at the he for she campaign in
2014. it's for feminism so we should
agree with it right
no no
we should it's for women apparently
feminists want you to agree with them
but i don't think they have your best
interests in mind so i don't stop it i
ignore that
no okay so we're going to be reacting
and just getting you know traditional
housewives perspective on emma watson's
thoughts so let's
let's begin the video oh guys before i
start don't forget subscribe to the
channel like the video and go subscr
subscribe to ally's channel thank you
yes it's going to be the in the
description because
she does like advice for women and she
gives very good advice i do i do i have
no fans so
okay let's let's go
and now let's turn to a young woman who
has chosen to lend her voice to this
well thank god
very important solidarity movement she's
a leading british actor an advocate for
gender equality in her own right she's
been involved with the promotion of
girls education for several years as
part of her humanitarian efforts she's
visited bangladesh
zambia recently returned as we just
heard my thing is
she's all here for gender equality but
like she won she was in the harry potter
series yeah so like also she's an
anomaly so
what i don't know what fight for
equality she's really looking for the
patriarchy's against her i guess it must
be hard being young it must be hard
being a young millionaire right
too hard why don't you let me let the
patriarchy do that to me
like i'll sign up like i'll bring the
lemonade and the cookies that's the
problem i don't know from uruguay on her
first mission with un women ladies and
gentlemen please join me in welcoming to
this stage our co-host and the un
women's global goodwill ambassador
emma watson
she's killing that dress though i'm not
even gonna lie yeah no it was a good
fashion move yeah she looks good
[Music]
[Applause]
she's such an independent woman but did
you hear like the the cute music that
they put on for her
they're like
let's take it back to elementary school
they would have did it for a man i guess
equal i don't know what would what would
be a man's intro song definitely not
that like that's the gender inequality
she should fight is the whack music
[Music]
your excellencies
un secretary general
president of the general assembly
executive director of un women
and distinguished guests
today
we are launching a campaign called he
for she
i am reaching out to you because we need
your help
we want to end gender inequality
and to do this
become a plumber
for the equality
yeah yeah women want equality but
not not when it doesn't serve them
the the whole thing is confusing for me
because she's like the strong
independent woman but she doesn't really
seem that confident to be giving her
speech like she's looking down a lot
well i mean i would be nervous too but i
mean if you're if you're gonna be out
here fighting for gender you know in a
equality and you're gonna be in a room
of men you might want to command
presents so i don't know i think emma
watson is uh covertly feminine
she just seems like a nice lady so i
don't know why she's single and
childless so i don't know i need
everyone involved
this is the first campaign of its kind
at the un
we want to try and galvanize as many men
and boys as possible to be advocates for
change
and we don't just want to talk about it
we want to try and make sure that it's
tangible
i was appointed so she wants to get
young boys and men involved to combat
gender inequality
but honestly like men have made things
as equal as possible for us yeah yeah
all of the inventions that women use
that make our lives easier were are
oftentimes uh invented by men so
like the band-aid the tampon those were
both male and male invented for their
wives well and honestly most girls don't
want to be equal like we want a guy that
can take care of us while like the kid
when we have kids at least early if you
ask most girls
and most girls don't want to be plumbers
they don't want to be bricklayers they
don't want to do the hard jobs like emma
are you signing up to do them in the
name of equality
i'm dead ass put your money where your
mouth is you know i saw i saw
construction workers the other day this
is so funny
and i saw a woman on site for the first
time ever i saw a woman
but guess what she was doing
i'm waving the flag it was close she was
just holding the slow sign
slowing the stop sign i was like no the
red hill is everywhere
okay but yeah we got it emma it must be
really hard being a millionaire actress
like you know the fact that she's single
and childless i think that's her problem
honestly she's like this was when she
was younger she's hot enough to get a
dude yeah she's probably been proposed
to multiple times yeah too yeah yeah
hyper root me
as good one ambassador for un women six
months ago
and the more i've spoken about feminism
the more i have realized
that fighting for women's rights
has too often become synonymous
with man-hating
if there is one thing
i know for certain
it is that
so i'm i'm curious to see what she
offers up as a solution because the
reason why feminism is perceived as
man-hating is because it is because they
do they hate men yeah they're not
they're not nice at all and they shame
women like myself who choose to stay
home they say like some of the most
awful things um my gosh i think i've
i've had people wish death upon me for
i think choosing to stay home and you
know be effeminate or women have told me
oh you're defined by your man and it's
like well if he's a good man and i'm
defined by my marriage who cares and
they say things like men are trash men
are the problem ugh men i'm like how do
you how do you not hate men like what if
they went around saying women are [ __ ]
you wouldn't think they're dude you
wouldn't think they're women hating yeah
i saw that in a social science degree
too they would have random scenarios
that always ended up like man shaming
but if you were to flip the scenario on
women then it so the scenario was this
is when i was in the social work program
they were talking about you know just
admonishing men but i offered up you
know hey this conversation is kind of
weird like we tend to do this a lot
do you think that we'd be able to have
the same conversation like about a woman
being flat-chested would it be funny
then yeah and oh my god what they say
they just made a pivot they like nodded
acknowledged and moved on because i
think they thought i might have been on
to something so yeah it's weird how
normal it is to be miss andrews like try
try hating on a woman see how far you
get no and that's the thing like like if
feminism feminists were equally as loud
about men's issues like in the criminal
justice system women get three times the
amount or no men get three times the
amount of prison time for the same crime
as a woman
and so it's like
where are the feminists where is it
where's the equality it's only they only
want feminism when it benefits us so
that's why we can't take it seriously
yeah i don't man so i'm a latina i grew
up in a lower socioeconomic status and i
always
and to this day i think feminism is an
upper-middle class white woman thing
it's like something that they do when
they get bored to me it seemed like much
ado about nothing and i think
you know most minority women just want a
good man to be in the home and feminism
goes against them and then like they get
to like pat themselves on the back like
they're doing so much what are you doing
i'm not you're just like talking to
people and telling them what to do yeah
we're only two minutes in too so this
will be fun
this has to stop
for the record
feminism by definition
is the belief okay this is too hard to
get through i'm like raging okay
so no no because feminism the root word
is fem everything that's fem is good
female feminine
but then everything that's bad is it's
that root word pater so the patriarchy
is bad right but peter means father so
everything that's wrong in the world is
male defined so if feminists want it to
be taken seriously they would call
themselves egalitarian because choosing
to be true i don't feel about that oh
i've been shamed for being an
egalitarian too color me shocked but
yeah if you want to be taken seriously
to movements you got to be out there for
men's best interests as well because i
mean
you birth men like women birth men
that's the thing how can you hate men
when like brothers fathers like i can
think of like like 10 off the top of my
head male figures i had in my life that
were really good men and men are so
willing to like help women too that
sometimes you'll be getting on this
train and it is not cool
all right let's let the rich white lady
talk thief
that men and women should have equal
rights and opportunities
it is the theory
of the political
economic
and social equality of the sexes
i started questioning gender-based
assumptions a long time ago
when i was eight
i was confused being called
bossy
because
can you imagine being an eight-year-old
and like thinking you have the right to
direct the play
like
emma you're brilliant i'm sure like you
probably have the talent to do it but no
no adult like i think if a boy did that
i would also call them bossy
well i think that it's probably one of
those things where you're allowed to
exercise that kind of autonomy as a
child so maybe it was like a group
project kind of situation where like
kids could lead but
you know if if you get called bossy it's
usually because you're not leading well
like i i don't women with power
it's my opinion
sometimes they don't act the best and
you know if you want to if you really
want to get into the red pill statistics
of it uh women when they lead countries
historically speaking
have initiated more war than men so
right yeah i don't know that yeah it
sucks that's so interesting
i mean i would i would you know i'm a
woman i'm emotional i have i i started
i feel like this [ __ ] did what
france did what we going there now oh
we're going now
i wanted to direct the plays that we
would put on for our parents
but the boys were not
when at 14
i started to be sexualized by certain
elements of the media
when at 15
my girlfriends started dropping out of
their beloved sports teams
because they didn't want to appear
muscly
one at 18
my male friends were unable to express
their feelings
uncomplicated to me oh boo hoo okay like
i don't know this is so stupid this is
like the most first world problems oh
i stopped playing recreational sports
because i didn't want to have too much
muscles like okay that was a choice live
with it like don't if your friends
didn't want to do it who cares well i
think oftentimes feminists just can't
cope with the fact that the world is
sexist and that was a lesson that i had
to learn myself and i learned that by
trying to be a combat medic and they
passed me and like certified that i
could be one but pretty sure they were
lying because i can't pick up a man
in in full kit with you know the weapon
and the body armor so there's just no
way but
women don't have to be afraid of the
world being sexist you can just see it
for what it is and then work around it
if you if you need to because so those
girls that quit sports because they
don't want to be muscly they don't have
self-esteem they don't have conviction
because if i i y'all can't tell but i'm
a brawling woman i lift heavy and you
know it's uncomfortable for my physique
but it makes me happy and my husband's
okay with it so you just have to be
confident in the decisions that you make
without athleticism and not be so easily
used
about trade-offs yeah yeah
there's no such thing as a decision
without any consequence and that's what
i believe feminists have a hard time
that's what they want they want no
consequence they're not gonna get it no
they're not gonna
go ahead keep trying sis i decided
that i was a feminist
and this seemed uncomplicated to me
but my recent research has shown me
that feminism has become an unpopular
word
women
are choosing not to identify
as feminist
apparently to agree i call that pretty
accurate to me i mean
i mean you know i mean
if women aren't even backing you then
like maybe you should
like read the rules
read yeah read the room
good good social skills if you're if
you're watching there's reasons why
women don't want to identify
as a feminist if i thought they made
sense i'd be on board but i don't oh my
god what if
like who gave her a bigger platform
after women were like no
no please don't no no they're like are
you guys they're like are you guys
feminist and they're like no no no and
they're like now she's basically going
on a bigger platform and saying please
please be a father
no
no if you have to convince me that i
need to be something like it should just
speak for itself so i'm done
i'm among the ranks of women whose
expressions
are seen as too strong
too aggressive
isolating
and anti-men
unattractive even
why
has the word become
such an uncomfortable one
i am from britain
and i think it is right that i am paid
the same as my male counterparts
i think it is right
that i should be able to make decisions
about my own body
i think
[Applause]
the pay gap isn't real it has been
debunked so many times and women are
just like la la la la la la la you need
to be oppressed
kyra you were in the freaking harry
potter film
like name a better gig name a better gig
like i can't
it's too much i might stroke out on
camera i'm sorry
like i don't i don't believe in aborting
someone what about the baby's rights oh
well then you're asking too many
questions they're like what about the
fact that they're terminating other
women like we just don't pretend we're
just gonna pretend this isn't happening
and you know you
can like everything she's saying she
can't do she legally can do it's not
even matching reality us as women in the
west we have autonomy over our bodies so
she's not making any type of sense how
much did she make in
harry potter films that's fine i just
want to know does she make more than
most men
let's see emma watson
she better not be complaining because
got paid more than her like what the
well usually men are paid more for
acting because they're better actors
i'm gonna earn 70 million
wow you're talking about equal pay equal
equal pay what percent of men make 70
million well you ever notice that the
the actresses that complain about not
getting paid the same as men they're
just not very good like jada pinkett
like that's why she hates will smith
that's what i think right
he's just a better actor than her it's
not it's ain't no pay gap i don't know
why women do the whole like la la la
situation about it it has been illegal
i think since the sixties to pay a woman
differently
for the same job so i don't what if
you're living in a world racially that's
like me going up to
um
like like donovan or fresh infant being
like equal pet why aren't i paid the
same i don't know they do more work like
they they do more i don't know i don't
know it's gotta be impressions yeah
you're right it's oppression
i think it is right
that women be involved on my behalf
in the policies and the decisions that
will affect my life
i think it is right
that socially
i am afforded the same respect as men
but sadly
i can say
that there is no one country in the
world
where all women can expect to receive
these rights
no country in the world can yet say
that they have achieved gender equality
can you get on a stage this big and not
research the stats that you were talking
about the paycap has been debunked so
many
times and it's literally because women
want to do different things
we're not interested in the same things
as men that's why we don't get paid the
same we don't we don't do plumbing we
don't do we don't want to be engineer we
don't want to do that stuff
yeah and you get like how can you be so
dumb to go on a world yeah i'm serious
can you imagine like giving this big of
a speech no
i can't i'm not pressing google like
well i think women just kind of i hate
to say this
but i don't think there's that many good
female entrepreneurs i don't think they
have the same grit and you can see this
is a common thing with uh
entrepreneurship and speech giving for
women they just don't research right so
like michaela peterson she had rollo on
yeah he was supposed to talk about his
book yeah
they never talked about the book also
she never looked up his content she
didn't even i don't even think she read
the book so like women
are not that good you could have gotten
a call with me i could have coached you
yes please email us before you do more
manospheric collabs so we can help you
we'll help you out girl
[Laughter]
yep female entrepreneurs they're on my
they're on my ish list for sure
these rights
i consider to be human rights
but i am one of the lucky ones
my life is a sheer privilege
because my parents didn't love me less
because i was born a daughter
my school did not limit me
because i was a girl
my mentors didn't assume that i would go
less far because i might give birth to a
child one day
these influences were the gender
equality ambassadors that made me who i
am today
they may not know it
but they are the inadvertent feminists
who are changing the world today
we need more of those
and if you still hate the word
it is not the word
that is important
it's the idea this is what pisses me off
is
like i think the world is easier if
you're a young attractive woman
it is what do you mean
yeah like
you're telling me emma watson what would
you give her one time i could hear like
a nine um
i'll give she's pretty average in my
opinion she'll get a seven from me using
a seven
i think she's got a plain jane face
she's like uh that girl from
uh what was the character
bella bella swan oh yeah yeah yeah is
that is that the name from the from
twilight i think her face is like pretty
symmetrical but yeah okay okay let's
let's average on nate i gave you yeah
yeah she's the average white girl she's
cute
yeah so you don't think you were treated
better and maybe got more opportunities
because you're good-looking
apparently not she she got the role of
hermione just you know for being an
absolutely ugly haggard woman it had
nothing to do with looks also
feminists always talk about being a
woman as if it's like this horrible
thing sometimes it's awesome bro i love
being a girl i don't i i've always been
told my whole life i can do anything
dude
like my dad might have pushed me
and most people around me like it's a
femme centric society so they're
literally
like if a girl becomes anything it's
always like she gets the cover like the
first female astronaut the first female
anything that's part of the reason why
our platforms are successful is because
we're women women
and the ambition behind it
because not all women have received
the same rights that i have
in fact
statistically
very few have been
in 1997
hillary clinton made a famous speech in
beijing about women's rights
sadly
many of the things that she wanted to
change
are still true today
but what stood out for me the most
was that less than 30 percent
of the audience
were male
how can we affect change in the world
when only half of it is invited
or feel welcome to participate in the
conversation
men
i would like to take this opportunity
to extend
veda oh my gosh
oh my god it's like a bad car accident
i respect the people that were walking
out
well it's like
okay
hey hey men
please come to our speeches about how
much you suck in a process you really
need to do this
we don't hate men but we're they're the
ones that we're calling out but we don't
hate men yeah and you know i can't
imagine why why wouldn't men
want to come to these people because
it's boring it's the same reason why i
don't like why people don't watch the
wnba like no frank no i know you're an
athlete but it's just not fun i don't
even watch the wnba
yeah play basketball
[Laughter]
gender equality
is your issue too
because to date
i've seen my father's role as a parent
being valued less by society despite my
needing his presence as a child as much
as my mother's
i've seen young men
suffering from mental illness
unable to ask for help
for fear it would make them
less of a men or less of a man
in fact in the uk
suicide is the biggest killer of men
between 20 to 49
eclipsing road accidents cancer
and coronary heart disease
i've seen men made fragile and insecure
by a distorted sense
of what constitutes
male
success
men don't have the benefits of equality
either
we don't often talk about men being
imprisoned by gender stereotypes
but i can see
that they are
and that when they are free
things will change for women
as a natural consequence
if men don't have to be aggressive
in order to be accepted oh no she did
not
oh no she did not
oh yeah you know what's funny
she's out here giving a speech to men
about being a man she's not a man also
she's not picked a man
to
go through life with but she knows so
much about men
she knows so much she she knows what her
girlfriends tell her i see this i see
this a lot with feminists too the ones
that decide to stay single listen to my
advice but even if men took my advice i
still wouldn't date them like why would
i listen to you
well and clearly the men
aren't listening to you either she's
complaining they're not listening
but i don't know i don't know why she's
talking about what they want like they
should want to go to her speeches
do you i think that the suicide problem
and i could be wrong about this but i
think it's like men being confused
because women will say oh i want a weak
man i want a weak man but like that's
not what we actually want and there's a
consequence in society for that for
being like
like they call it emotionally vulnerable
but i don't i think it's more just like
not being able to control your emotions
well i i also
i know this to be a fact men just
process and express their emotions
differently
but i think the bigger problem when it
comes to male suicidality
is that men don't go to other masculine
men about their problems because i mean
that's how it's supposed to be you're
supposed to be able to go to war come
back and share that you're having a hard
time with other men but if you have
effeminate men to go to if you can only
go to women who aren't going to
understand you well of course you're
going to feel like you don't have
anybody to share that stuff with but
yeah we gotta
make men masculine again so they can
help each other go to the cme there you
go oh yeah yeah dot shout out donovan
yeah
women won't feel compelled to be
submissive
if men don't have to control
women won't have to be controlled oh
wait i wanted to ask you about
submission do you feel like in order to
be a housewife you had to submit
so i had to do submission work because i
grew up in a lower socioeconomic status
in a single mother home
you're supposed to submit to trustworthy
authority so you do business right if a
man knows more than you and is trying to
help you are you going to challenge are
you going to take his advice i'll take
his advice yeah and that's why that's
why you're successful there you go yeah
but so i'm from the midwest and the
standard out there this is just the
demographics of the area so 76 white so
the standard is a white christian
two-parent household so those women out
there they don't have to do submission
work and i don't think you do either
because you had good parents that like
raised you and helped you to cultivate
that kind of a personality but it's
women that just are raised on the whole
you can't trust men you can only trust
yourself you got to get an education you
got to join the military these are your
options never rely on a man it's when
you grow up like that is when you need
to do submission work because it's
normal somebody's out there trying to
help you and better your life that
you're like okay i'll do it
no and i i just think like now
it's but this was seven years ago she's
still single
she's gonna stay single
and that's and it's because she doesn't
like think she needs to submit to a guy
at all like men i think are built more
logical than we are like they're and
that's why i trust a lot of guys with my
decisions like i have my managers a dude
and a lot of my decisions go through him
and i don't
like i don't think that's a bad thing
but according to emma it's the
patriarchy well uh she can she may cry
about the patriarchy when she's 70 and
wrinkly and ain't got nobody
yeah i mean i could i could cry in a 70
million dollar match
did you see her other video where she
talked about the pressure of turning 30.
no i didn't yeah that'll be maybe next
time yeah maybe maybe that'll be the
next
both men and women should feel free to
be sensitive
both men and women should feel free to
be strong
it is time that we all perceive gender
on a spectrum
we're clapping
beta
if we stop defining each other i like
this girl she's like i don't stand for
that
she's like nami
if we stop defining each other by what
we are not
and start defining ourselves by who we
are
we can all be freer
and this is what he she is about
it's about freedom
i want men to take up this mantle
so that their daughters sisters and
mothers can be free from prejudice
but also so that their sons have
permission to be vulnerable and human
too
reclaim those parts themselves they
abandoned
and in doing so
be i don't like it when people say just
be yourself because
i think that in order to function in
society you have to change things about
yourself like you can't act like a
toddler the rest of your life
i agree so you can be yourself if you
have the game to back it up like our
platforms are reasonably successful
because we are ourselves and we stay
true to ourselves but if you suck as an
individual yeah like you might you might
gotta i mean i got bullied a little bit
as a kid and honestly i deserve to yeah
yeah i mean the same for me i i did not
know how to shut up for years and it set
me back and somebody would have probably
called me
you know a a witchy woman and they would
have been right
sometimes criticism is okay yeah you
gotta be less of yourself sometimes or
learn to be different like they're just
arguing like the the bad points you know
what's a form of sexism that actually
men
might need to let go of it is uh women
we say like a lot
yeah and that's like a normal thing for
a western woman to do so that that would
make more sense to complain about and
say hey guys give it up we're going to
say like like you look like like but
she's she's doing this instead talking
about things that don't exist
i don't think she said like in the
speech so good for her good job emma
more true and complete version of
themselves
you might be thinking
who is this harry and it's a really good
question that's exactly what i was
thinking
she's finally speaking for me it's rich
white women she's going to save us
thank god
all i know you don't even know
about this problem
and i want to make it better
and having seen what i've seen
and given the chance
i feel it is my responsibility
to say something
statesman edmund burke said
all that is needed for the forces of
evil to triumph is for good men and
women
to do nothing
in my nervousness for this speech
and in you do you see how she's fiddling
with her hands mm-hmm that means that
she's not confident so if you're not
confident on something you're speaking
on it can be a self-esteem thing but it
can also be that what you're speaking on
just might not be worth talking about
might not be a hill worth dying on so i
don't know this just doesn't come across
to me it's like she's actually out here
pumped to stand up for women but maybe
that's because it's all constructed off
of belief and feelings maybe there's not
much to defend
it really
i just
i just think she doesn't know what she's
talking she clearly didn't google the
stat
like she clearly didn't press google
before i'm like you're not going to
google a stat you're citing
you know what social sciences call the
the pay gap now it's the motherhood
penalty and it's like you damn skippy
there's going to be some type of penalty
to reproducing okay you get the
opportunity to have children why is it a
penalty
girl you get to you get to stay home
while the guy works you get to make it
make sense like
that's a privilege not a lot of people
get to do that like that is a privilege
fact you're going to tell me
oh it's a penalty like that the audacity
the audacity
in my moments of doubt
i've told myself firmly
if not me
who
if not now
when
if you have
i could think of a lot of people
i could think of like a lot of people
that would have been better like i don't
know someone that doesn't have 70
million dollars
i just don't know why rich liberal white
women feel like they have to save the
world like
sis just honestly some people some some
women really should just go back home
and bake some cookies because this is a
that's a lot we should do that later we
should it'd be fun fire that's how it's
fire
when opportunities are presented to you
i hope that those words will be helpful
because
the reality is that if we do nothing
it will take 75 years
or for me to be nearly a hundred
before women can expect to be paid the
same as men
for the same work
15.5 million girls will be married but
here's the thing it could never happen
because when you give women more choice
they choose jobs that pay less so if
you're giving us the choice like why are
we trying to change that you know what
people don't talk about is the benefit
of capitalism
like the whole housewife situation we
can only do that because of capitalism
housewives and communism tell you that
right now we all working at the camp
so yeah i mean if you give women the
opportunity to leave the workforce to
take care of their family
they might just do it right but you know
feminists don't don't quite understand
in the next 16 years
as
children and at current rates
it won't be until that's the one thing i
can get behind that that's messed up
yeah that makes sense that makes sense
we agree with you emma well
i don't know if you saw this but
california keeps trying to lower the age
of consent right so that's one weird
thing and the other thing
is that sometimes because i'm not a
reluctant republican and maybe putting
stuff out there talking about like we
need to lower the age
for marriage like no no we don't no we
don't 18 sounds fun 18 sounds good to me
2086
before all rural african girls can have
a secondary education
if you believe
in equality
you might be one of those inadvertent
feminists that i spoke of earlier
and for this
i applaud you
we are struggling don't tell me what i
am emma
i am whatever you say i am you're a
feminist and i get to define myself as
not a feminist no no pick me nation it's
a it's a party of three it's me pearl
and porsche yeah yeah
we'd be lonely not not you though
for a uniting word
but the good news is
that we have a uniting movement
it is called he for she
i am inviting you to step forward
that never that never kept like i've
never heard of that before
so
i think i've heard of it but you know
through the grapevine it's uh
probably more apropos if she called it
bettas or us like that might be
that might have been a better name i
don't know oh gosh
to be seen
and to ask yourself
if not to ask yourself i feel seen emma
if not me
[Music]
when
thank you very very much okay first of
all i could think of a lot of people and
i can think of a lot of times that like
people have given speeches before eva
you're not you're not unique i'm not
gonna lie to you
there's
there's some questions that i think
rich liberal white women need to stop
asking themselves and the whole
if not me then who just threw it in the
trash this is a dumb that's a dumb ass
question i'm sorry
[Applause]
i could that one could go that one can
go
thank you very very much
okay
wow i want to find someone who's not
clapping in the audience
like bring them back so
what do you think
i can't believe you made me watch that
no i'm sorry it was it was so bad and so
sorry for all the pauses it's just what
i encounter this stuff is the delusion
is over 9 000 only a woman who is so
successful because we have capitalism
that afforded her the opportunity
to be an actress and to be a very
successful actress only a woman with
immense privilege would even do the
mental gymnastics to come out with this
speech like the audacity like you are so
70 million it's the same thing with that
hot chick scarlett johansson she's
complaining she doesn't get paid enough
honestly i just think she's a bad
actress
she's just hot yeah yeah
like it's just like no i'm saying like i
don't think she's that good of an
actress she's just hot you know we
should see if meryl streep has ever
complained about her pay meryl streep is
a wonderful actress we should try to
look at some pros and like you can't
complain about a wage you accepted you
didn't have to accept it yeah you could
have said no pay me more and they could
have gone and found another actress
like it's all about what wage are you
willing to accept that's why when people
say like pay me what i'm worth well
you're only worth what you're willing to
accept
do you struggle with that in business
asking for your worth or you know asking
for raises
um i mean
i really i only worked in a real job for
like two years
um that i did youtube so i would say i
struggle with that with brand deals like
like countering and just not taking the
first offer they give me yeah i'm not
good at the whole pay me more because i
don't want to come across as asking for
something that i don't deserve but i'm
also bad at evaluating my my own worth i
guess in the market so i just rely on my
husband for that kind of stuff i do too
i literally go to guys because i just
think they've been naturally they're
naturally better at it some girls are
really good at it and some girls can
actually do that it's just it ain't me
yeah being feminine in business can be a
challenge i'll tell you that but it has
its advantages too because you can you
can come to things with like a feminine
touch yeah you can get along with people
better i think than a lot of guys i
agree you probably network easier being
a social butterfly for feminine for sure
yeah but yeah yeah so my thoughts would
be that this woman is incredibly
privileged and doesn't know what she's
talking about but she's going to save
all the brown people she's going to do
it yeah
oh my gosh i think that emma
needs to chill she kind of has a little
bit the last couple years now
yeah i think she left the public eye
let's see if she's in a relationship
let's see emma watson she might have
found a man by now i i do not know okay
no
actually no by myself don't wanna be oh
[Laughter]
oh thank you i just don't she's so
pretty she could be married if she
wanted to but you know whatever maybe
she'll hit the epiphany to find out
okay guys um if you guys like these type
of reactions let us know in the comments
go subscribe to ali's channel she gives
some really good advice to women i ask
her for it all the time so thank you i
can attest very good advice
um like the video it helps us with the
algorithm don't forget to subscribe and
i will talk to you guys next time bye